foreign
yes
wait wait what back up our very first
non-female guest no the first sorry
Britney was the other one right Brittany
was our in-person segment interview you
were the first full-length female guest
you're full-sized okay full size anybody
trying to say that you're just a tiny
little portion of a human they're wrong
you know they can they can take that and
shovel where the sun don't shine so uh I
am in fact excited to talk to you
and
let's see I thought it was only natural
that I had Isaiah and I felt like it I
wanted you on first but then I was like
it'd be rude to Isaiah if I you know if
I yeah like you want to be on first for
sure but I was like more excited to have
you on but then I'm like I think you
would feel so now he's out of the way
that he feels important now so
especially the sides though yeah we we
can we can finally move on to the to the
real interesting interviews here
um
so as I was describing to you before
something that is going to be a little
bit unconventional is
us doing starting out with a segment I
like to call this is why we can't have
nice gyms because some of these I was
like
I feel like these would be a good
starting point for a conversation I've
never done this with a guest before so
that's another first you are banging out
so many firsts of this episode it's
insane now I don't even want you to read
I try not to give it away they're gonna
be looking there let's take a look at
this first one here
and I just want you to react to it okay
[Music]
so that's the real important part is you
should be dating a gym guy because he's
not going to look at other women he's
going to look at other men what do you
think about that
um I don't agree he is gonna be looking
at other men but he's also gonna be
looking at other words ah okay okay
because there's this common gym trip
that that guy's like when you get
muscles you know women assume that other
men look at them but
like mainly it's going to be guys giving
you attention that's sort of a meme
amongst guys yeah yeah yeah give us your
experience on that hmm
I mean I've I've really always gone for
gym guys I feel like oh really yeah yeah
like literally ever since high school
yeah I just like the muscle yeah yeah
and do you because here's another thing
too I've noticed or like maybe you might
be able to attribute this do you think
being in shape yourself allows you to
have that confidence to go for somebody
else who's in shape because sometimes
people will project their own
insecurities like I'm out of shape I
don't want some guy or women have come
to me like and I'm not even in like at
times when I'm not even in my best shape
and they're like
they'll like apologize for their bodies
you know they're like I'm sorry I'm not
in shape I'm like I wasn't even thinking
about that I'm not like wait a second
let me get another fat calipers before I
have sex with you right see I was just I
was a little insecure at first because
um up until like
two years ago I didn't really start like
weight lifting so it's really skinny and
frail and then the reason I started
working out is because it's honestly
kind of sad but it's because people
would make fun of me and call me a
pancake and stuff like that and I was
like wow I really do need to gain weight
wow so you actually listened your haters
were right I did listen to the haters
and I started I started trying to put on
that weight yeah but it is you know
what's cool about that is like because
I'm not saying you should never listen
to any like you know we're going to talk
more about this in general but
there is this idea that like if
somebody's being excessively negative
like they couldn't possibly have any
sort of point
that's not my nuanced perspective on
people [ __ ] on you like sometimes
they're all right like you can point
something you know you can be a dick and
be like you have a zit on your face like
that doesn't make me not have a zit on
my face yeah you could be saying in a
mean way but like I I think you get
better at sifting through like no that's
delusional okay maybe they're right in
this regard but I also think I remember
reading this article about a kid who was
like I'm getting bullied at school for
the clothes I'm wearing and his parents
are like instead of being like don't
listen to the bullies they're like well
let's go get you some cool clothes and
like dress like the cool kids and then
it solves the problem right and it
almost is a similar situation to what
you're describing because you're like I
was really skinny and like it made me
aware of the fact that you did want to
make a change and then you changed it
and nobody's calling you a pancake no
are they they still are they still
not as bad though not as bad though yeah
so the problem kind of is solved a
little bit but like at first when people
first saw me on social media I was like
oh my God she's a pancake like really
and what age was that
um 14. yes no actually I was uh
a freshman or sophomore in college okay
I think I was a freshman yeah you know
it is it's a good reminder too that
people like can have insecurities about
being too skinny as well and sometimes
even though we look at like you know and
I think women are guilty of this a lot
too like you look at it when you're like
oh my God Jesus oh man like I don't even
know but it's like well remember that
person is also potentially dealing with
insecurities if they're born that way
we'll get back to that a second let's
take a look at this other one
I broke my bosu so this guy's doing one
arm dumbbell bench press on a bosu ball
and oh God what do you think is gonna
happen
um and then we're putting the volume on
it
why the heck would he do that
that's my question here
okay
uh you're right so I always wanted to
get your reaction too to this kind of
stuff because it's like
at like what level of sympathy do you
naturally feel for somebody who's kind
of doing something inherently stupid at
a gym which is what is the benefit of
like balancing on a boat so I get if
it's like the only thing you have
available to you to do bench press but
if there's a bench right there and
you're doing the one-off which I think
probably puts pressure in a more
isolated area on the bosu ball
and then also I liked how he's like I
broke my arm but like he's like writhing
on the floor like if I broke my armpit
I'd get up and like all right I need to
go to the hospital yeah yeah yeah oh my
God so when you look at that you don't
feel sympathy
not really I feel like he was just
trying to like show a cool trick got you
noelle's a sociopath guys so yeah she
has no empathy I am a sociopath
I mean I do
but she didn't know that was gonna
happen yeah I feel you I feel you she's
not a sociopath she's a reasonable
person
let's take a look at the next one here
oh my the capture this is are you
kidding this guy's doing the most
aggressive muscle ups I think that's I
could catcher uh taking a break from is
this sped up no no hope that I Catcher
by the way I was making fun of people
who do aggressive muscle ups that's the
coolest thing in the world
um it's a black gentleman in a
commercial gym he's wearing American
striped pants if they're not America you
know flag colors they're like red and
white and yeah the thing that you're
looking at is he's doing the jerk at the
end it's like he's trying to launch
himself at the end
um and shaking the whole thing there
that person is doing that and so okay
I'm gonna ask you this you walk into the
gym and see a guy doing that the guy's
obviously got a great physique he's
going shirtless and doing that what
would your reaction be to seeing
somebody do something like that
I would Pro that kind of looks
impressive to me uh-huh like is that is
that good for him or no it's certainly
strong I would say the
that's a good question because it's like
when I think of a muscle up it's like
the easiest way to get yourself up into
that locked out position yeah he's so
strong that he can like throw himself up
at this backwards angle rather than like
having to put his like upper body over
this and hunch over and then like press
out the dip part of it yeah and so
it's good for him in the sense of he's
almost like it's almost like doing like
a clapping push-up it's like is it
clapping push-up good well obviously
push-ups are so easy for you that you
can Propel yourself into the air so
I mentioned the female perspective on
this because it's like this guy is
strong and confident it's like oh here's
this buff guy like showing off his
strength does that ever get into
douchebagville where you're like oh my
God you roll your eyes at a guy who like
seems to be potentially just seeking
attention yeah yeah I mean I don't know
not not in this case I feel like I don't
know yeah that kind of impressed me I
thought that was cool because I can't
even do a pull-up that's a good honest
answer yeah and I also feel like you're
trying not to be racist because he's
black so let's okay let's run the clip
of the white guy doing that and then see
if she has the same reaction
you're horrible
[Music]
what do we have yeah let's do a eating
chicken and rice be like
chicken rice every day today
so I wanted to show this to you because
you've been eating more healthy recently
yeah you know yeah but uh-huh sorry I've
recently gone off the um
the wood sword the plan a little bit
because of stuff like that put your
hands up because of that yeah it makes
me like want to gag now when I'm eating
chicken and rice or just like meat any
meat and rice like something plain like
that like I'm like
now yeah you've given me a lot of
yourself so I don't know if you can
reveal that here but you know I've
gotten a lot of meal prep uh meals from
Noel and I I don't know if it's stuff
you'd eat anyway but like you
you've recently experienced and I guess
you know hearing that you've always been
lean
like or on the leaner side
maybe you haven't had to do this strict
diet because usually people are really
incentivized to get lean yeah I mean
like women want a small waist guys want
the ABS so like that's what you're
always fighting against like when you're
going well I'm doing this because
you'd never done like a deliberate Diet
before so maybe you're I can imagine you
eating this stuff and you're like why am
I even doing this yeah it's like I don't
know why it's so hard for me to eat a
lot of like because
essentially I'm trying to gain weight
but yeah do it the right way yeah so
it's just like a lot of clean food yeah
I'm just like I could eat a lot of dirty
food but
a lot of clean Foods
I can eat a lot of dirty food oh wow
Noel I know I can break it down I don't
think anybody's heard you've seen before
at least online you don't sing a lot
that was that was the first time I've
heard you
I wasn't a real voice what it was a fake
voice it was a fake singing voice it was
an AI generated and you're like here I
have my little singing uh
recorder here that I used to play well
um but you are trying to gain weight
yeah because I want to um grow my
pancake so
I was telling you that grow that pancake
into a it's hard it's a full stack you
have a just a single they have a side
order of it yeah over here I just have a
single order of a pancake not it's not
like
it's not a short stack um whatever I was
gonna say but
my mom and my sister and my brother they
all have
a nice bubble butt
they all have fat asses the three of
them and my dad
your dad's ass look my dad's I'm pretty
sure it's looking flat so so I got the
dad Ash jeans and it's like I'm grateful
because I have the muscle genetics which
is kind of awesome like I'm not big or
anything but I do have like the
whatever what do you call it I would say
what you have is really good insertions
yeah good muscle shape you have a good
frame like your your shoulders are Broad
and you have long arms so like
um you naturally like already sort of
look a steady you're predisposed to look
aesthetic yeah would you agree yeah like
here flex your arm for everyone
yeah you already have like a nicely
shape bicep right oh yeah you have a
really big peak actually it's the left
one that's better I can see that so but
yeah even when I'm like skinny you could
still see like my muscle yes shape
um
but yeah my butt doesn't grow easily my
fat doesn't go there sadly right because
that's always the thing it's like
and maybe that's something we could talk
about too like a little bit later is
because girls will buy like oh I want
this booty program or whatever actually
I was talking to Val last night we were
shooting sketches with her and I'll use
her like she has this booty building
glue guy she sent it to me yeah yeah
right okay I think we did bring that up
actually that she was like
um have you used it yet no not yet okay
but she's pretty hardcore about it but
she's somebody who like was very very
thin and actually she was like wasn't
she fat as a kid yeah and then got
really thin for like competitions and
then but in the last year or whatever
she's posted pictures of herself I was
telling this to her and I'm like I feel
self-conscious like commenting on your
ass growing but like you do put it on
social media and uh so you know she
didn't make me feel weird about it it's
just like kind of crazy like her like
her growth yeah but you have to follow
people like that because you're like
don't show me some girl who's just got
A Gifted butt as far as like her hip
shape and yeah uh her fat deposits you
know but there are a lot of women out
there going like oh get like me like I
have a fat ass and you can have one too
but it's like but you didn't grow it
from nothing born like that yeah you
didn't start from scratch like Noel now
there is a girl who started from scratch
absolutely nothing back there just
kidding I actually know it's bad I can't
joke about it because it's sensitive but
I don't agree with you
um
you know I still think that a lot of
women would look at you and go that's
not a pancake that's a baby Peach
um
girls on Instagram be like trained arms
and shoulders today
for those uh for the people who are
listening at home so this is something
we've talked about before a little bit
how what's your take on this because
like
guys make fun of girls a lot for this
but it's also like
you can't just caption everything like
here's my ass you know like you're
showing off the goods and guys do this
too and I'll give you examples of like
okay if I'm a muscular guy I'm posting
my muscles if I have cars if I have
wealth if I have whatever I'm doing on
social media that is a place that's
pretty accepted to like show the thing
that increases your status if you're a
young woman with a great body or a great
butt or whatever like and that's your
money maker and you see that like also
if you're a professional on social media
and you're like well everybody wants to
see this part of my body you know like
girls with gigantic boobs it's like well
every picture is going to be in their
moves because they learned that nobody
else gives a [ __ ] about any of their
body part that they have so
the thing that's funny to us right is
just that they're like they'll put the
quote or whatever you know about the
Bible and then have their ass up but
what is this what's your thought process
on this as somebody who has to
participate professionally in social
media
like my thought on girls posting their
ass and being like yeah like trained
arms and shoulder straight or like
sneaking it in is this something you do
so you get the instinct to do it if I
had a big ass yeah I would be doing that
all the time yeah I'd be like like
flexing my tricep and but like my like
yeah just drink tries today
but like I I prefer to post from the
front because
um
I take pride in my abs yeah and my
shoulders so I'll like Flex like yeah
yeah so you do that do you think of
yourself as like and maybe there's a
stigma attached to being like I have a
six-pack or I have a really lean stomach
like
you like there isn't that same exact
joke around there but you consciously
think of like I want to put my best
feature in as many pictures as possible
for sure yeah yeah yeah it's sad because
I know like when I like post more of my
body like it'll get more likes yeah but
like that does get to your head when as
a girl it does because like yeah like I
posted something wearing all the clothes
and it didn't get that many likes right
that's just social media you know like
yeah you kind of have to deal with it
yeah well and and we'll get into that
too how many more do we have with just a
few there is this is why I wanted to
bring these up because I feel like we're
kidding hitting on little uh
things that I want to delve back into
but just the nature of social media and
engagement and like how you deal with
that psychologically especially as a
woman that's definitely something I want
to come back to all right let's go to
the next one
this is when that pre-workout kicks in
10 seconds after taking the Pre-Workout
oh my God
no
are you somebody that takes pre-workout
um no not really yeah um once in a while
I will um but my boyfriend Isaiah takes
it for this reason
just to make himself shift yeah pretty
well pretty much called out like
literally this whole episode is just
gonna be about throwing ice into the bus
all these different habits soon his
bowels moving he drinks his pre-workout
on the car as soon he as he gets to the
gym he's rushing out of the car and
taking a [ __ ] in the bathroom he's
almost like he's like a warning to you
you know yeah you're like this is a a
lesson and what not to do as far as
avoiding diarrhea at the gym
but you don't take pre-workout at all
because some people ask me about it and
I'm like not everybody needs to take it
I do like once in a while when I'm
feeling like I need some energy but I um
sometimes it'll make me feel nauseous
yeah sometimes caffeine can make me feel
nauseous so that's why I don't really
take it a lot but if I feel like oh I
need it today like I'll take him that's
fair and that's also a good thing
because if you get like
I always tell people look if you're
taking it every day it's not going to
work the same every day yeah your
receptors are eventually going to get
desensitized to the stimulant that
you're taking then you need more of it
or it just doesn't hit in the same way
so by Taking It Whatever let's say once
a week
you're doing yourself a favor so you can
really get up for those days that you
actually do need it and you're not
desensitized and going through more
you're taking multiple scoops and
um right yeah yeah I just think that's a
good approach because I still only take
like the serving size is usually Two
Scoops out only ever take one scoop yeah
so I know I think that's a good thing to
stay at all right let's let's power
through these other ones
I told her we were doing push-ups so
this guy's got his leg he's got his kid
on his back his wife is holding his legs
around the carpet and he's like oh
and he just starts oh my God he takes
his feet and Rams her face right into
his [ __ ] uh
so I thought about this and I'm like it
kind of looks real to me right like the
the reaction
it feels somewhat sincere it's I know
it's always tough to to to do but like
her screaming right what's your take on
it does look real to you
um at first it looked real but then I
was like nah usually those type of
things are always staged right you know
you're just that's more of a comment on
like literally everything you see online
is staged right oh yeah if Isaiah did
that to you and it wasn't a prank would
you talk to him afterwards
um
I'd probably ignore him for like five
minutes yeah like
get over here oh my God that looks like
it kind of hurt right it did it was like
that was that looks traumatizing so you
know what I know you were curious about
what we have on this table over here and
just to answer your question this
Burning question that you have this is
happy hippo was that I was curious yeah
you legitimately were and that's why I'm
saying it because we're a podcast that's
grounded in reality this is happy hippo
Kratom right here you can get it that
happy
hippo.com it's no longer happyhippo
herbals.com it's just happy hippo they
cleaned it up it's like when the
Facebook became facebook.com well that's
what we all think of now it's just that
clean URL go to happyhippo.com use promo
code thick boy three C's and you will
get 20 off for the rest of your life
and if I can open this and you ready for
this
okay I'm going to Cheers you and you
don't have to drink it I'm gonna I'm
gonna let you drink enough notice cheers
me ready
okay yeah you can actually smell it
before we
what do you think it smells like berries
oh interesting I think it's some berries
to Cherry there we go and I do this oh
mine's Berry Pom-Pom
brain activated Tim Mark where'd you get
that shirt from that's so funny that you
should ask a lot of people have been
asking me about this shirt and it's
actually from Oak and stoneclothing.com
you know every week I'm wearing another
absolute Banger of a clothing device on
my body from oakenstoneclothing.com and
if you're somebody who's not hello Mark
Carly who gets the stuff for free
because they love mud Oak and stone
you're going to use code hella h-e-l-l-a
for 10 off at oakenstoneclothing.com and
look if you want to look like this body
not included but maybe it can fit your
frame if you're an athlete if you want
to look good if you're tired of these
big boxy shirts that don't fit right and
make you look like a refrigerator okay
check it out and if you're not in shape
well this can be the motivation to get
you in shape get you looking like an
athlete and someday yes you can reach
Greek god status like your boy here okay
you're crazy no that's just what Isaiah
says okay I'm just saying other people
are saying this online and I'm just a a
vessel for that statement to come to
your brain and eyeballs and then I think
we have one more that I really want to
get your take on so this guy says you
got to work so hard they can't stop
staring this guy's walking to the gym
looking really buff everybody's looking
at him and then we pan down oh my god
oh that's one of my favorite guys
actually Skyler Scott is his name
um that's actually it has a lot of butt
cheek based humor you know he'll be like
filming a selfie camera and then it's
like you hit the mirror and his pants
are off or whatever I appreciate that
kind of stuff you know that's funny he's
uh he's found his own lane there
um
and that's one thing too that like
you know
you're probably somebody who people look
at in the gym do you ever get like are
you conscious people looking at you in
the gym has this ever been an issue for
you
um will tell me like oh the guy's
staring at you or you'll be with a girl
and they're like this girl was looking
at you or whatever the notion of like
people staring at you and even defining
Yourself by that like that sort of
attention in the gym is this something
that you court or you reject or like
when you're in a gym environment see I'm
not really like the type of girl to be
like he was making me feel uncomfortable
in the gym uh-huh I don't really I've
never really been like that unless you
someone actually was making me really
uncomfortable yeah but um I'm not too
conscious of it like people staring at
me in the gym unless it's like they're
like
yeah my every move but no I really like
don't notice it or care too much yeah
because you sort of expect a certain
degree of like I mean even when I'm I
know for myself it's like I just look at
people yeah me too you know I look at
people I'm attracted to I look at people
I'm not attracted I just look at people
yeah maybe that's something I need to
work on no same and then sometimes I
realize something for the restraining
one yeah you know but uh I literally
just realized wait I was like staring at
that person for like 30 seconds I was so
rude at me because I'll be thinking of
something else and I'll just be like
right you Zone and out and then they're
like do you want to make out no no I
no thinking about popcorn huh oh I'll
notice in the gym though like when
people are staring at Isaiah they're
like girls I'll be like that girl like
can't stop staring at you right so
that's what I maybe should hone it on is
is when girls notice other girls staring
at you I'm always oblivious of people
staring at me and I also like even if a
guy was staring at me I wouldn't go like
that guy's giving me a bad look I'd be
like hey be probably staring at my hair
or I don't know I feel like I'm
oblivious to it too right but then girls
will always be on your ass about like
girls that are staring at you and I kind
of I actually like hearing that it's
like oh thank you for like having my
back and letting me know who's paying
attention to me yeah you know especially
when it comes to to women or it's just
flattering I guess but
um
I do think women are more perceptive
about that in general like you're
staring at my man yeah oh yeah I'm
really cautious of that yeah and because
that and that can be a way of flirting
in and of itself for women right I think
we've talked about oh yeah for sure
staring like yeah
right because it can't it can
potentially be
like permission to come talk to me
exactly yeah yeah and do you flirt with
guys like that or have you I know
obviously you don't you don't by staring
you walk around all of Los Angeles with
blinders on prize as request but
um before I was dating Isaiah though in
the gym yeah now that I think about it
whenever I had a little gym Crush yes
yeah but I try not to make it too
obvious but right of course not but what
okay give us some other tactics
um
but listen like it never worked out like
I remember this one gym Crush I had
um I was just always like staring at him
like damn he's cute
um and then
um I went to the lengths of trying to
find his Instagram because I had no idea
what his name was uh so he was talking
somehow no I was literally like full on
stalker mode yeah this is like really
like crazy to say I'm like but I went to
my gym I went into my following
dude you got to get it done somehow I
looked into the gyms following and I was
like tried to find someone who kind of
looked like him and I I thought I found
him and then so I requested to follow
you yeah and then oh because it was a
private account yeah yeah so I'm like
[ __ ] like that's so weird and that he's
gonna be like why is she requesting to
follow me like how did she even find me
but whatever I did I was [ __ ] it I'm
gonna make this move yeah he
accepts it like almost right away
and he has a [ __ ] girlfriend oh wait
but was it him yeah oh it was him oh it
was him I'm the guy who kind of looked
like him but I'm expecting him to be
like oh and then that guy's hitting on
me but I'm like no I didn't mean to
follow you it was a totally yeah but
you're saying you follow him and of
course he's taken yeah all his um then
he's like no no dude I can be single I
can what's up all his poster with his
girlfriend so I was like all right so we
accept it I'm gonna be deceived I'm
gonna unfollow yeah
and then how long did you wait though
did you wait a tactful amount of time to
unfollow
um
I don't remember I think it was like a
day or two I wasn't gonna follow but
then I remember
I don't know if he once I started to
gain followers he like dm'd me and
unsent it or followed me again it was
something like that that I remember wait
wait wait wait wait he he once you
unfold him he dm'd you and potentially
unscented or like no once I started to
gain followers oh okay yeah what's the
follower count looking like at this
point in time that you're describing oh
probably 100K yeah just kidding
come on
um yeah like 100k on Instagram she'd
already no okay maybe we should start
this will be a good segue into your
origin story I am self-conscious a
little bit to like
get into things that I know you've
talked about this on other podcasts and
you know maybe you're tired of talking
about it I don't know but like okay you
know when did you get on Instagram and
then when did you start to be like oh
people like looking at me I will give
you the full rundown absolutely so I was
one day
um I was chilling with my dance team and
this girl was like oh my God you guys
have to get tender like I gained like 2
000 followers from Tinder oh yeah and I
was like
okay yeah so I downloaded Tinder I never
had a dating app before in my life and I
was like oh that's cool that's so funny
and how old were you you're in high
school no I was um a freshman in college
okay cool yeah dancer we'll get to that
too because I thought that was an
interesting little tip but I learned
about you like yeah as part of guessing
your personality type I think yeah oh my
God it's the answer for like my whole
life yeah but I put my Instagram in my
bio on Tinder and I just like let it fly
from there you just let it yeah and so
over the course of like a few months I
gained like
five thousand followers from Tinder
which is a lot which is a lot from
Tinder like geez you just started so
where what was your follower account
that I know I'm obsessing about the
numbers but it's like if it's a large
percentage it started at like
one thousand or two thousand right so
that's crazy increase and all this frame
in terms of like any time somebody with
like a million plus followers has like
posted me like I was in the liver King
story the other week and it's like I'll
gain like a thousand followers from that
so 5000 is actually a very significant
number yeah it is just passively being
like what's up you know yeah so I
thought that was really cool at this
point I'm like like six thousand seven
thousand followers yeah
um I'm starting to post more modeling
pictures yeah
um because I thought that's what I
wanted to do I started doing shoots and
stuff yeah
um and then my friend Jesse who I went
to college with yeah we only like really
kind of just like knew of each other
yeah um
Big Time Fitness Jesse James West yes
um
so basically he reached out to me he's
like he saw me doing the modeling stuff
he's like do you want to model my merch
and I was like yeah sure you're like
yeah I'll be a merch model so we did it
and then while we're hanging out doing
that he's like
do you want to be in one of my YouTube
videos I have this idea like
because we mashed on Tinder and stuff
like that and I was like
because we did match on Tinder that's
also another funny thing oh yeah yeah
separately
um
so my career actually thank you Tinder
right this is a great advertisement for
Kenya
but um whatever I'm saying
I was like oh I don't know I don't
really have the best social media
presence I don't know because I've never
you know spoke on social media or
anything like that but I was like sure
so
I ended up doing that I was really shy
and like Meek and like little and skinny
that's when all the pancake comments
starts coming oh really yeah but
that's like like you at that time I
guess like I'm just gonna hone in on
that for a second you
like you generated a little bit of a
following and then he gave you he
already had a larger following so he's
exposing YouTube yeah YouTube Instagram
following and then and then that's where
you get a certain percentage of people
coming in trying to [ __ ] on you yeah
which I can relate to or I think a lot
of people can where it's like you're
kind of building your own thing but then
like
you cross over to something else that's
like you might also get an influx of
people who are supportive but you're
like oh my god I've never had like a
thousand people comment how ugly I am
one day or whatever so it's like um you
know fire hose of kind of information
some of which is negative but so
basically what happened was he had I
think 100K subscribers Maybe
maybe
um
but
his videos wouldn't consistently get
like 100k views or anything like that
yet like he did have some bangers
beforehand but he we always talk about
how that video
was kind of the first to just like blow
up like it got like so that was yeah for
him too because I know it was big for
both of us it was really crazy that like
you know obviously I don't think this
but you know people would be like
you use Jesse James West for clout or
something yeah we always we always talk
about this is a sentence that would come
out of my mouth obviously yeah because
it's like well he asked you to be in a
video like that's all that matters but
what I think is interesting about this
is it was it was very successful for him
people liked you two in this video and
liked you on camera too because up to
that point you've been modeling and I
think a lot of girls it's always
interesting I'm like I want to hear you
like you look attractive and maybe some
people can't pull this off I happen to
think you're also compelling on video
but like up to that point you hadn't
really put yourself out there like this
no yeah so I really
like I I don't know if it weren't for
Jesse I don't think I would be on social
media at all right right like so that's
just kind of like maybe I would have
kept posting and like that it could have
happened from there but I really don't
think so you didn't have the impulse to
be on camera no speaking to it and
acting and doing everything because I
think if you now like doing all the
skits that you do with Isaiah and I've
told you this before but I think out of
the girls he works with I'm always like
you know like Noel's the sleeper
actually even though he's like you're
dating each other so it's a natural fit
but I'm like I really like your acting
and I'm always impressed with like
how you do things in one take or he
gives you Direction so I'm always in the
mindset of like you're actually a really
good actress thank you you know and it
is true and like and just funny too
because that's what I think a lot of
people don't realize like and maybe
before I met you too
my assumptions
were you know not that oh this girl's
also going to be funny oh yeah whatever
it was I'll be projecting you know
whatever oh here's a hot young
influencer like she's not gonna be like
willing to be silly or goofy like you
are but you are I feel like I'm one of
the goofiest people all right no it's
great it is that's great and like you're
like you're the type of person who's
seen that obviously Isaiah knows but
like a lot of people don't know that
about me because on social media I don't
really portray that like maybe in my
YouTube videos you'll see it a little
bit but yeah I don't know I do because
you're also an introvert yeah like it's
an isfp folks for anybody who's uh
paying attention to the
16personalities.com results that we do
um the Myers-Briggs stuff and this is
something we'll talk about in a second
but you are I have thought this from the
beginning and then it's sort of
confirmed with you know knowing you more
but you're an introvert yeah so I I'm
not going to go out of my way to be like
to someone I don't know hey how are you
like I'm Noel like oh my God it's so
great to be you because I'm too shy I'm
like kind of insecure in a way so that's
not my but if someone introduces
themselves to me I'll be like oh yeah hi
how are you yeah but I am a very shy
person when I first meet you yeah so
that can sometimes come off to people
she was like a [ __ ] but as soon as I
get comfortable with you like
that's when my true personality starts
to come out I'm not really like
introverted anymore yes and I've gotten
to see that and you're also just like
what I like about hanging out with you
and Isaiah is like you're open to my
silliness and like sometimes I'll do
something and like I could be doing
something that I think is funny I don't
need people to laugh at it but like I'm
doing it for myself and I just pay
attention to like who's even like on the
radar for picking it up you know whether
it's subtle or big or whatever so I just
feel like we're a lot of times on the
same wavelength of like silliness where
you're receptive to like me being a
goofball whatever with your cats or just
around the house or whatever
um so that's why I always think of you
as like oh she's fun she's creative
she's funny and yes like left your own
devices you're not gonna lead with that
yeah you know you maybe don't Define
yourself in that way or feel the need to
like show that off to everybody but you
know because what if they'll sometimes
they get insecure that they're gonna be
like what damn she's weird like what if
people don't get my humor yeah yeah well
that is I mean and it's also like
because if you were to look at your
online presence and like you are
modeling you are putting bikini stuff on
you are doing like things that let's put
this in a category of like
I'm sexy Noel right
yeah there is a self-consciousness
naturally about like well I'm also like
Goofy and that's part of me but you feel
like maybe it would detract from this or
you feel like well I know I'm accepted
over in this category will I be accepted
over in this category and funny is
another thing that it's it's very easy
for people to be like not funny yes you
know exactly how to look in the mirror
and be like I know I'm hot or whatever
or like you can like you get more
feedback you know from yourself about it
or enough reinforcement but funny
especially as a girl and guys a lot of
times will go out of their way to like
tell a girl who's trying to be funny
like you're not funny oh yes out of like
their own anger and insecurity that's
why I think I'll never post like say on
Tick Tock like my true like funny
personality on Tick Tock because it'll
just be a bunch of guys like you're
annoying like you're not funny girl this
is why girls aren't funny like right
because I'd rather not I'd rather not go
there yeah well I hope you do someday
because
this is another thing that I wanted to
talk about with you because I know look
Isaiah ratted you out he was like no he
told me how behind my back you told him
that you think haters secretly really
bother me oh my God
no by the way this is not something I
was upset about at all you know what I
want to explain it I will definitely let
you do that this is something I think a
lot of people think so you can give your
perspective and then I also want to hear
your perspective on like online
criticism that you get and how you do it
okay
so I what I was going to say was I
didn't say oh my God the haters really
bother Mark I was like it looks like
they bother him when he like will
literally go back and forth and back and
forth back and forth it's like really
long I'm like on his stories and I'm
like yeah oh my God Mark right and so
you're no I and I totally related to
that I'm hyping it up like you know
sometimes these people do deserve a
response though yes and also like you're
looking at it from a Time perspective
you're going like
um this person we actually we talked
about it under the influence podcast
while you're in the room like so I'm
repeating this conversation for anybody
who hasn't seen it but oh yeah yeah it
is it is an interesting point to me and
I think a lot of people will say that
and even like the haters that I get are
these people who go back and forth to me
who would be like look how much you
wrote like you must be bothered now that
can be an indication that I'm bothered
right yeah if you are sitting there like
and you write this much if you're just
looking at that you might think
this person's devoting time and they're
using multiple responses but I so like
from the outside if you're kind of just
to look at a snapshot of that of course
that's a reasonable assumption that that
it would bother you my justification of
it is always just this feels like a
video game
almost said I've already won or like it
feels safe in the sense of um
if I'm angry it's because I'm like I
feel humiliated or I feel like ashamed
or that is coming from
a deeper place where that person has
genuinely gotten under my skin the
people specifically on Instagram who go
after me like
they're just not good enough to do that
you know and I still
if I was genuinely angry I wouldn't post
it that's what I always and maybe that
makes sense maybe it doesn't but I was
will say that because if I'm angry it's
like I know for me that's an L you know
so like if I'm sitting there going you
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate your you
know it's like oh God I'm being
inarticulate and eloquent not clever
yeah I mean it's hard to be funny or
whatever so I I kind of Justified as
like if I'm not angry you're gonna see
it because I'm gonna post it and make
content out of it if if I do get
emotionally upset by it
I'm going to feel ashamed about the fact
that they got on my skin and maybe try
to keep that private but look that never
happens because you guys suck
controlling me
um but with you I've been around you a
few times and I hope you don't mind me
saying this but
I've seen that people saying things to
you online does have an effect like
anybody like any normal person because
I'm always like look if this is
something like don't do what I do this
is my blueprint for me but most people
like why wouldn't you be bothered by
people shooting you online and so maybe
you can walk me through like that
Journey how you deal with it now what
you'd wish people would understand who
are coming at you in a particular way
and maybe watching this I'm just
remembering because you know sometimes
it gets me more than others like most of
the time I try to just not read the
comments and push it away but there's
one time recently when you were
literally there is the first time the
comments really got to me in a while
like I immediately started as soon as I
read one of the comments I started
crying yeah and it was just because
I did this podcast with um
it was Bradley Angelina and steiny the
whole thing was really a played out joke
like yeah the stuff between me steiny
and Angelina was and just between me and
Stein he was also always just a joke and
always just because I'm not in like
knowing like that much about steiny or
what the recurring joke is so what is he
doing to you and how are you responding
to that constitutes the joke so
basically yeah so basically everyone
knows I have a boyfriend so this stuff
was like always like a scare it was like
a joke
um steiny would pretend like like oh he
liked me and I had a crush on me and
stuff like that and like be like extra
like nice and yeah like and stuff like
would you consider him like the runt of
like the note boys because I look at him
I'm like and not to say that in a
pejorative way but like he's kind of a
smaller guy so I'll see him like going
back and forth with Brad He's not buff
but he's like getting into it but they
kind of like give him [ __ ] like he's a
kid brother or something I don't know
the whole dynamic but would you agree
with that yeah yeah it's kind of funny
where it's like like a lot of they just
kind of like trying to mess around with
him yeah he's trying right so he's kind
of like the recipient of a lot of [ __ ]
and then he's hitting on you like
shooting a sort of what would seem from
the outside to be like a desperate shot
yeah that might Garner sympathy for you
like come on give him a chance or
whatever yeah exactly so everyone all
the fans love that stuff they're like oh
give him a chance give him a chance come
on it's team steiny like stuff like that
yeah so we just thought that was really
funny and we would mess around with him
and make content about that
um but you would reject him in this in
these scenarios you would be like yeah
yeah basically in the content I'd be
like like uh like kind of kind of like
that yeah um
so that's kind of how this podcast went
that shiny was gonna be like Oh I'm over
Noel and here's my new girl Angelina
yeah and
people took it in a way that because I
was joking the whole time like literally
like it was a script yeah like it wasn't
a script that I was
acting literally acting
um
and people were like basically just
commenting down on my personality and
saying that I'm stuck up I'm a clout
Chaser
um
I am selfish
all this
I don't even remember half the comments
because I literally shut them out as
soon as I read them but they were nasty
and so they're not even yeah they're not
even physical
insults they're making moral judgments
against you claiming to make moral
judgments um it was either it was all
them were comparing me to
um Angelina which is fine I love
Angelina yeah yeah you guys are like I
mean you consider her one of if you're
not your best friend yeah yeah exactly
I've uh anytime I've talked to her she
seems super sweet yeah
um you guys I am genuinely glad that you
guys are friends like to me you guys
have a lot yeah she's she's super sweet
attitudes so um This was um also one of
I think it was Angelina's first podcast
actually oh wow that one so she was like
kind of just like shy and like cute the
whole time like her herself and you
wanted to turn the camera like she's
really a [ __ ] behind Candace no okay no
but she was a big herself she was like
um she's just pretending to be nice
people were like
saying that well first of all they were
saying that oh like
she's 10 times better than Noel and blah
blah and like all this stuff like in
every way and like or just you know just
commenting straight up about how I am a
horrible person and they hate me and the
thought of me nauseates them yeah all
this like nasty stuff and I would just
read and read the comments and I was so
upset like I'm talking about like mental
breakdown at night like texting people
like I don't think I can do social media
anymore wow and Steiny's one of the
people that called me up and honestly
like talked me down and I like really
appreciate it at the end he was like but
also like you're done hook up
and then you know he's like just throws
the phone
she's a [ __ ] he was like
you know he's kind of just like
reassuring me that
right because I'm sure he gets those
people don't know me and that like they
don't understand that you know it was
kind of like
this whole thing's kind of just been
like a scare and we're actually friends
and we all like each other you know
stuff like that
um
and but but I want to hone in on
something you said you genuinely felt
like you wanted to leave social media
yeah because I was like I genuinely felt
in that moment
I'm I'm not even kidding I fell in that
moment it's probably because I was
having like a panic attack but I fell in
that moment like I don't why am I doing
this if
everyone on the internet that knows of
me hates me yeah and that's genuinely
how I felt I was like they either
sexualize me or hate me I was like
there's literally no in between like I
feel like I don't have like people who
just like want to support right and I
was like and I feel like a lot of women
who are in your position probably feel
that that's a really good way of putting
it because like you'll hear women be
like I'm sexualized and my man brain
goes like well you are posting pictures
or something exactly make a living but
that I've never heard somebody say
either they sexualize me or just hate me
like I'm in this two category which are
both very strong emotions yeah and
you're yearning for somebody to like
just understand you and support you for
being you yeah and like
see I can't really you know be like how
could you sexualize me because of course
like I post I post stuff like that yeah
I never hear you complain about that
like you're not somebody who who I think
of at all oh no I would never
staring at my pants
yeah or like because you're grounded
that's a good thing that I'd say about
you is like you're grounded in reality
so like you know this is part of just
it's part of it of course yeah I've only
fans you know I agree yeah like um so it
comes yeah that's cool you wait so how
much is it but
um you know being sexualized and that it
just comes with it but in that moment
like I literally felt like I don't have
supporters like I was like why am I
doing this and yeah and now it was just
in my head like would I be happier if I
stopped yeah because it does really
really get to my head the answer is yes
um but what I was really going to say is
when you because I remember you showed
me the comments and I was like you know
this is a good microcosm of like how our
mind works is I'm reading through it and
in your head you're like every single
comment is saying this okay and I'm
going like
but it's not I saw three comments that
were nice
that were nice about me out of like
three thousand but they're also just a
lot they didn't have anything to do with
you so you're looking at in terms of
like who's nice to me and who's not nice
to me I could be misremembered it was
the main collection it was just like
all of the main comments that we're
getting all the likes and the top
comments and just like going into all
the recent comments they were all hating
on me all of them are hating on me and
it was like I just
oh it was really hard because it was
like the the first comment that everyone
sees because it was the most high
comment was just literally [ __ ] on
me yeah and so everyone you know how
people like to tag along they read it
and they're like maybe if they weren't
thinking that at first they see it and
they're like oh yeah yeah that's no
that's another thing too that I that you
know
how I deal with stuff like that like
first of all like I'm not your age so I
can't speak to how it would have been
like to have been bombarded with
negativity on that level at you know in
my early 20s I was a different person
back then and I had different
experiences and maybe I would have been
a little bit more equipped with that but
I also like went through like fraternity
hazing and stuff which is like a
deliberate approach to that where like
guys will try to break you down mentally
like and I think a lot of like male
initiation has to do with stuff like
that where
um you're being tested because out in
the real world guys will try to do that
to you you know viciously
is that why they do that
yeah I would say an all-male rituals
there's this aspect of like attempting
to break you down and make you quit or
like but it's imperations it is it's
crazy but you like part of being a guy
or like playing football for example
like what are the things you learn is
just you can have another grown man
yelling at you about how much you suck
guys will talk [ __ ] to you to the game
tell your horrible talk [ __ ] about your
mom say you know they want to do
terrible things to your family and you
have to stay focused and do the task
ahead of you right and there was a point
when I wouldn't have been able to do
that and that I'm exposed to this enough
you know like anybody there's some
things that can kill you like if you
have a peanut allergy peanut dust can
kill you but if you gradually increase
that
um you know uh sort of percentage over
time of of what that looks like you know
that dose of that poison you can build
resilience to that so I'm talking to you
I'm in my early 60s and that's something
that I've built up over the past four
years
no I was like uh-huh yes you are
um
no but that's something that I go like
you're you know I would hope that you're
going to get exposed to it and it
becomes
easier to deal with who you can
compartmentalize it when I hear it I go
um
those are
people who are immature or whatever or
you can you can find ways to dismiss
them like so when do you ever play the
game of like thinking about those
individuals saying this thing
and going where is that coming from is
it necessarily a reflection upon myself
because
I watched
I watched that podcast
um but to answer your question you
watched the podcast of of myself yeah
and in that time since I was not really
being myself like I was kind of just
like you know yeah like joking around
most of the time like I could see where
people thought those things about me but
then again I was just like
they can't see that I'm joking and that
this whole time this has like all been a
skit like I don't know why it like it
hurt my feelings so much that I think it
just hurts that people think of me
like the complete opposite than what I
am you know right you know what I mean
yeah no that is that is hurtful and
that's something that I can I would say
for me I know how important it is to
feel
understood or that's one of my primary
desires and maybe like I think when I
find out it doesn't bother so much when
strangers don't understand me when I
feel like somebody close to me
misunderstands me I know that pain yeah
that's that's true because I do look at
those comments like
you know just like when people hate on
my Tick Tock or like my Instagram and
it's like okay these people are
literally taking time out of their day
to leave a hateful comment like what
does that say about them right because I
can't imagine doing that to someone
correct that's so that's a good a good
little mental game to play is imagine
you're in that person's shoes and what
your circumstances would be in order to
lead you to that behavior and it's never
done it from a good place yeah like I'm
happy fulfilled I have purpose in my
life and community and I'm also doing
this I don't think that person exists
but I'm glad we touched on that I wanted
to talk a little bit about
like where you see yourself let's say
how old do you know
I'm 21. okay
next five years next 10 years do you
think in terms of that kind of of thing
because you've got a really great thing
going and I think you know you do have
an IT Factor two that's brought you to
where you are right
you know and I and I think you probably
have enough self-confidence to see that
in yourself and I encourage you to do
acting and stuff like that but I'm
always self-conscious about being like
yes I'm gonna encourage the person to do
the thing that I do because that's what
I know more about but what even my mom
always says it oh about acting she said
I want you to start acting she says that
Mark's a good actor that's so crazy she
loves my mom wanted me to say this she's
like if you don't shout me out and tell
Mark I love him like yeah oh that's true
and your mom is awesome your mom made me
these amazing like Mark Harley cookies
that I still need to post about actually
oh my God I didn't post it on the day
but like she made this whole arrangement
of like pictures of me and it's always
sayings all my yeah like you know a lot
of chatter or like haters will say
um all our little buzzwords that we that
me you and Isaiah use together it was
really really cool and I also just know
like I know a little bit more about your
mom and how she's helped you behind the
scenes and she seems like a really smart
and articulate woman she's the best she
wants you to to do more acting what do
you see yourself doing because I also we
didn't touch the fact that you did come
from a dancing background oh yeah I
heard that I was like you know what it
made sense it was like oh yes because
you're a creative yeah you know you're
somebody who actually uh I can I can see
that you
uh deep down have a yearning from
creative expression which is not
something to be taken for granted right
not everybody has that but you do and so
how do you see fulfilling that more in
the future
oh so see that question where do you
where do you think you'll be in the
future you sound like a job interview
but no it's always been so hard for me
is what I'm trying to say because
see I still don't know what I want to do
I never like I was like oh the social
media thing is kicking off I didn't know
what I wanted to do I was in college
yeah um I was you know studying
marketing so I thought it was Broad and
you know right right because you're
still in this phase of like you I always
forget sometimes and Isaiah's just
joined us in the studio
but I always I can sometimes forget
because you guys are actually really
mature in a lot of ways for your age I
sometimes forget I'm like I met this guy
like a year and a half ago or you've
only been doing like social media in a
certain level for a couple years and
like as you're kind of telling us it's
almost like by accident you're like oh I
wouldn't have even it's not exactly yeah
as a a kid you're like and I'm an abused
you like social media Megastar I think
Isaiah's more driven with his like
particular Vision or he articulates that
like you know like I want to be this he
literally yeah he knows I love that
about him because he knows exactly what
he wants to do and what he wants to be
and he's not going to stop till he
hasn't yeah and that's awesome but
you're you're also a very different
person than him
um yeah I am I I'm very different person
than him because I I think it's hard for
me to say oh this is where I want to be
in five years because I don't have a lot
of faith in myself which is like really
sad to admit but I I do know that and
well that's when the things I like about
you is that you are honest about that
yeah I'm gonna try to fake it yeah
you're like I can admit that like I
struggle with this and I think that's
what also makes you relatable I've
always struggled a lot like even when I
was in dance you know I've always
struggled with believing in myself yeah
and being like you know this is my path
this is what I want to do because I'm
like what can I do what am I good at and
that's you know so that's hard but
I have realized The more I've been on
social media what you know my dream
essentially would be like what I want to
do yeah but
I don't know can you tell me about that
because it maybe that's a better trigger
word for you like saying where am I
going to be in five years
that insinuates or implies that you're
the type of person to plan out something
based on a time frame but
I think it might be something you're
more just like you have a vision right
so yeah a dream or a vision so I've
always loved like modeling and stuff
like that
um since I was a in I think I started
like just costume modeling in like
seventh grade
um I did like dance costume modeling and
that was my first that was my first paid
gig yeah um and then I was like oh I
want to sign with a modeling agency when
I was a sophomore in high school but
then
I ended up being like eh about that but
still that's one of my dreams to this
day to like maybe get big enough on
social media where brands do reach out
to me to model for yeah to model for
them yeah that's what that's one of my
dreams for sure
um I also want to come out with once you
know once I figure out my skin situation
I love skin care stuff yeah like I was
telling Isaiah this the other day like
walking around like Ulta and like
Sephora and stuff like that like it just
makes me happy to like look at all the
products and see everything like I
literally go there because it's like
therapy to me like I love looking at all
that stuff and I was like actually the
opposite for guys were like what the
[ __ ] am I doing here I would like
coming out with like my own skin care
brand one day and finding out what
really works for me like this would be
years and years from now but I would
love to do that yeah or not because I
think you're on a great path right now
and I
I guess I'll wrap it up by saying
I hope that you come to terms with the
power that is inside you and I look at
you and see somebody who
is very powerful and influential and can
do so many things and I think you're
only just starting to like wrap your
mind around your own potential So when
you say something like years and years
from now I'm like I think it might
happen
sooner than you realize or you know
you'll realize the things that you're
capable of or how you know people who
are being honest with themselves really
perceive you in the world and so I hope
that happens sooner rather than later
and well thank you so much for coming on
so much that was a really great
conversation and I hope we do it again
yes we will future
bangers your best